STORIES, RAVING AND A OUT SOME
INCOME ANGLE AND OF THE YEAR
AWARDS.
I LOVE THIS TIME OF THE YEAR.
BELIEVE BEGIN TONIGHT, WITH
ESTABLISHMENT EXTREMISM.
THAT IS TO POKE FOCUS OF MY LAST
ANGLE 2022.
♪ ♪
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT 2022
IS NEARING A CLOSE.
AND AFTER THANKING THE ECONOMY
AND GETTING US TO A PROXY MODE
WITH RUSSIA, AND CREATING A
FULL-BLOWN DRUG CRIME AND
SMUGGLING DISASTER ON THE
BORDER, THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
PRESS SUPPLICANTS, STILL WANT
YOU TO BELIEVE THAT TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S ARE THE BIGGEST
THREAT WE FACE.
>> EXTREME RIGHT WING
POLITICIANS, AND ON THE COURT
SUPREME COURT HAVE GOT THEIR
BACKS.
WHO WERE THEY COME FOR NEXT?
>> THERE'S A PRICE TO PAY IN THE
RIGHT WING EXTREMISM IN THE
SELECTION.
>> IT IS ALL ABOUT THOSE RIGHT
WING EXTREMIST GROUPS.
IN DONALD TRUMP.
>> FOR THESE RIGHT WING
EXTREMIST TO BE HIJACKING OUR
NATIONS FOUNDATION, IT IS
INCREDIBLY DISCOURAGING.
THE RACK NATURALLY, THEIR
DEFINITIONS OF EXTREMISM AND
RADICALISM ONLY TO APPLY TO ONE
SIDE OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
AS USUAL BUT THE BIG DANGER THIS
KEEPS SHINY OBJECTS SEEK TO
DISTRACT YOU FROM THE REAL
EXTREMISM PLAGUING OUR COUNTRY.
THERE IS.
FOR WHATEVER REASON, I WOKE UP
AT THREE AND THIS MORNING, AND I
WOKE UP AT THE START.
THEN I MADE THE MISTAKE OF
REACHING FOR MY PHONE IN AND
SHOULD NEVER DO THAT.
THEN I MADE THE MISTAKE OF
SCROLLING THROUGH THE FIRST 260
PAGES OF SELF OF THE SENATE'S
4,155 PAGE $1.000000000000 ON
THE SPENDING BILL.
NOW, THE POOR PROJECTS IT FUNDS,
THE INSANE INCREASED 10% IN THE
PENTAGON SPENDING.
IN THE UNFORGIVABLE LENGTHS, TOO
LOW FOR ANY CONGRESSMAN TO READ.
IN THE TEXT KEPT SECRET UNTIL
AFTER THE ELECTION, THE FACT AS
CAN BE RAN THROUGH BY THE BUSH
CHENEY RING BEFORE A NEW G.O.P.
HOUSE HAD GETS TO HAVE ANY INPUT
IN THE YEAR YEAR, THE FACT THAT
REPUBLICANS MAKE LEFT THE DEAL
MAKING THE 80-YEAR-OLD
RICHARD SHELBY WHO STEPS DOWN
FROM THE SENATE IN JANUARY.
NOW, WHO THINK HE DROVE A HARD
BARGAIN FOR FISCAL RESTRAINT?
OKAY, ALL OF THIS IS EXTREME.
BUT THIS IS WORSE THAN A
SPLENDID RUN, IT IS A SPINNER
ENTIRE.
NOW, IT'S A PERFECT SCENARIO FOR
MITCH McCONNELL WHO WANT ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM HIS AND HIS
GANG.
IF THIS LEVEL OF SPENDING WHICH
REALLY POPULAR, THERE'D BE OUT
DEFENDING A PUBLIC E.
SANDERS McCONNELL, AND SHALL
BE, WILL, AND THE ANGLE AND
TRIED TO CONVINCE YOU OF HOW
GREAT DECELERATES.
BUT THEY CANNOT.
AND A TIME WHEN MOST ECONOMISTS
THINK THAT WE ARE HEADING INTO A
RECESSION NEXT YEAR, THE
PUBLICATION OF THE FOCUS ON
FINDING CUTS AND COST SAVINGS.
NOT MORE SPENDING.
IN THE DENNIS' ACTIONS IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION, THEY ARE
RADICAL, AND EXTREME.
ALL OF THIS, SHOULD OF BEEN OUT
BEFORE THE VOTERS COULD VOTE IN
THESE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
FRANKLY, I SHOULD'VE BEEN ALL
BEEN OUT BEFORE LABOR DAY.
IT HAD BEEN, ACTUALLY A POINT OF
DISCUSSION, THIS MIGHT HAVE BEEN
A VERY DIFFERENT ELECTION
OUTCOME.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN A FIERY DEBATE
OF THE VERY LEAST.
BUT THE ESTABLISHMENT KNEW IT
THROUGH THIS ON THE BUS MONTHS
AGO, BUT THEY HIT THE BALL.
THEY ARE THE EXTREMISTS.
NORMAL PEOPLE KNOW THAT CHINA,
IS A BRUTAL RED DREAM AND
ESSENTIAL MANUFACTURING SHOULD
BE BROUGHT HOME.
IN THE ESTABLISHMENT KNOW SO
THAT THE CCP DOES RUN A
SLAVE STATE, BUT I STILL BELIEVE
WE CAN ENGAGE MORE NOT LESS WITH
THEM.
AND THEY ARE THE RADICALS.
NORMAL PEOPLE KNOW THAT PUSHING
A TREASURY AGENDA FOR KIDS IS
DEMONIC.
DEMOCRATS TRY TRANCE PHOBIA,
THAT IT IS ENTRANCE WILL BE A
WIMP PARENTS SPEAK OUT AGAINST
GROWN MEN DRESSED AS WOMEN
READING TO LITTLE CHILDREN.
THEY ARE THE EXTREMISTS.
NORMAL PEOPLE KNOW THAT EFFORTS
TO HAVE A LOT OF OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY MEAN ECONOMIC
SURRENDER.
BUT DEMOCRATS DID THIS TO GET
AMERICANS USED A TO LESS
FREEDOM, NO LOWER STANDARD OF
LIVING TALK ABOUT RADICAL.
NORMAL PEOPLE KNOW THAT
RESCINDING TITLE 42 WAS A RED OF
COURSE POLITICAL MOVE.
THE BRIGHTEST PEOPLE DID IT WITH
THE GOAL OF CHANGING AMERICA
FOREVER.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF A
POLITICAL EXTREMISM.
ALLOWING MILLIONS TO COME HERE
AND A BOGUS ASSIGNMENT CLAIM,
ONLY TO BUST LOCAL BUDGETS,
CROWDED SCHOOLS, CITIES, TOWNS,
BURDEN OR HEALTH CARE COSTS, NOW
THAT IS A RADICAL.
A NORMAL PEOPLE DO NOT SUPPORT
OUR FUNDING IN THE WAR IN
UKRAINE AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
BUT THE ESTABLISHMENT IS FINE
WITH THE PROTECTIVE WARS EVEN
ONES WITH A CLEAR PASSIVE PICKED
VICTORY VICTORY OR SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC SUPPORT.
THIS MY FRIEND IS A RADICAL
APPROACH TO FOREIGN POLICY.
IN NORMAL PEOPLE CERTAINLY KNOW
THAT OUR INTEL AGENCY SHOULD NOT
BE COOL COORDINATING WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES OR ANY
ENTITY WITH THE NAME OF SENSORY
AND SUPPRESSING DIVISIVE
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
BUT A POLITICIZED FBI, THAT THAT
IS EXTREMISM.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE.
THE TRUE RADICALS, THEY ARE NOT
AT THE RALLIES, OR ON
TALK SHOWS, THEY MEET IN SECRET.
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
AND THEN FOCUS ON THE DONORS,
NOT THE PEOPLE.
BUT OUR POPULIST MOVEMENT IS
DESIGNED TO TAKE THE POWER AWAY
FROM THE RADICALS ARE THE TOP OF
SOCIETY, AND THEY'RE GIVING
EFFECT TO THE NORMAL,
HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
WHO LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND ONE OF
FACT.
IN 2022, WHICH AFFECT THE HOUS